- Welcome back, y'all.
I'm here with Mike Colter,
and on the line from
New York is Hoda Kotb.
Give it up for 'em!
(audience applauds)
All right, so, in this
time of global pandemic,
we're always on the phone.
We are also not allowed to touch anything
another human touches,
which means, no games that
involve hitting a button
on a podium.
So, fear not, though, people,
in honor of Hoda's new book,
"This Just Speaks to Me,"
we have a solution in the
form of the game called
Hoda the phone.
(phone rings)
♪ Hoda the phone ♪
- Hoda the phone. We're awesome.
It's thick with the dad jokes today, Hoda.
Okay. Here's how it works.
Mike Colter and I each have a phone.
Hoda will ask questions that have to do
with scary movies in honor of Halloween
and Mike's new show "Monster Land."
After Hoda asks the question,
we will hear the sound.
(phone rings)
Whoever grabs their phone first,
and gives the correct
answer, gets the point.
If you're wrong, the
other person can steal.
Most points wins, but Hoda
the phone, there's a twist.
If you touch the phone before it rings,
you're disqualified from the question.
I'm pretty sure that my
producers put that in
just to screw me. Pretty sure.
I'll play it for the right
side of the audience.
Mike is playing for the left.
The winner gets a $200 gift
card to OtterBox for their side.
You're welcome.
Okay, so Hoda, let's go.
What's the first question, ma'am?
- All right. All right, here we go.
In "Carrie" -
- [Kelly] Uh oh.
- What did the other students
dump on Carrie at the prom?
(phone rings)
- Am I talking to you?
What am I doing?
I'm going to say it out loud?
Pig's blood.
- What?
- Yes.
- Oh my gosh.
I've never seen that movie.
No, no, nope.
- Okay. Kelly, you talk smack.
Let's go, babe. Get in it.
- [Kelly] I don't do scary.
- The title of this scary movie
is also what you might say
to someone whom you want to leave.
(phone rings)
- Who you want to leave?
Bye. Bye.
"Bye, Bye, Birdie."
Get out of here. Get out!
Oh! "Get Out!"
- Duh!
- Oh, my God. I said "Bye, Bye, Birdie."
- God, I was like, I was struggling.
I was following, you.
I was like, bye, bye, what?
- Okay, one, one, kiddos.
One, one, here we go.
- God.
- What scary movie is
based on a real life doll
that lived in Key West, Florida,
and was allegedly placed
under a voodoo curse?
- Is that, wait, is that -
- Oh!
- No!
- So, that doesn't count.
So I win by default, right?
- That is so wrong.
- Right? She picked it up early.
- I think so.
(phone rings)
- Okay. I'll take a shot.
A real live doll.
- I mean there's only one, right?
- It's "Chucky," right?
"Chucky?" No?
- No, dude, sorry.
- It's not "Chucky"?
- "Child's Play."
- That's the doll's name,
though, Chucky, "Child's Play."
- I think that kinda counts.
I think that kinda counts.
- [Mike] That counts.
- [Hoda] Yeah, you get
it. You get it, Mike.
- Yeah, gimme that, gimme that.
- Okay, here we go. All right.
So, it looks like the scales are tilted.
- Well, ring the bell.
Don't wait five hours.
- No, give it three seconds.
- Here we go.
What does Jack Nicholson
say when he finally
breaks through the door
with an ax in "The Shining"?
(phone rings)
- Here's Johnny.
- You know what I was thinking,
actually, it was Redrum,
but that's the kid, Redrum.
It's murder.
I actually didn't remember that.
- All right, you sit and watch me play.
- I gotta be honest with you.
I ain't never seen that either.
- Sit and watch me play. I got this.
- [Kelly] I'm out.
- I love this game.
- Okay, here we go.
Kelly, this one's triple or nothing.
So, you can actually win.
- Okay, thank you. Thanks, Hoda.
- [Mike] Okay.
- You're welcome.
A former cast member of "The Office"
went on to direct the scary
movie called "A Quiet Place."
Here's the question.
What was his character's
name in "The Office?"
- God, that, I should know this.
A friend of mine is going
to kill me for this one.
(phone rings)
- I'm... John?
- [Kelly] Jim?
(buzzer rings)
- [Hoda] Jim.
- Jim! Was it Jim?
I thought it was Jim,
but I was too afraid.
Oh my gosh, triple or nothing, sucker!
- I should have known that one.
- Obviously, Mike just killed me at that.
- [Mike] I did.
- But because this is the
Kelly Clarkson show, y'all,
everyone in our house seats is getting
a $200 gift card for OtterBox.
It's not only the number
one most trusted brand
for smartphone protection,
they have cases for
Apple watches, AirPods,
screen protectors and more.
Thank you so much, Hoda.
It's so lovely to see you.
- Love you, Kelly. Bye, Mike.
- Bye!